This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Whenever a group of people come together, there are always a few who steal the limelight. They may be gregarious and outgoing, or funnier, or more athletic. But I've noticed over the years that the people who are the center of attention on day one are very often not the center of their groups by day 62 or day 912. This is true of college students, new employees at a company, even family. Over time, the accomplished musician turns out to be a one-note opera. The athlete who dazzled on day one starts to sound boring.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。每当一群人聚在一起，总会有那么几个人抢尽风头。他们可能热情开朗、风趣幽默，或者更有运动细胞。但这些年来我注意到，第一天成为焦点的人，到了第62天或第912天时，往往不再是群体中心。无论是大学生、公司新员工，甚至家庭，都是如此。随着时间推移，那位才华横溢的音乐家结果只会单调的几招。那个在第一天惊艳全场的运动员，也开始显得索然无味。
The great storyteller turns out he has only a dozen stories and he keeps telling them over and over again. In time, groups often gravitate to the people who are connectors, the folks who are genuinely interested in others. They are often great listeners. These are people who put others first, who don't imagine they know everything. This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion story on our subscription feed,
那个伟大的故事讲述者，到头来发现他其实只有十几个故事，并且还在一遍又一遍地重复讲着。久而久之，群体往往会被那些“连接者”所吸引，也就是那些对他人真正感兴趣的人。他们通常是出色的倾听者。这些人把别人放在首位，不会自以为无所不知。本周的《隐藏的大脑》以及我们订阅源中的一篇配套文章，
Hidden Brain Plus, we examine the science and psychology of humility. It's a quality that is often underappreciated on day one, but much in demand over the long haul. And while most of us don't associate humble people with being particularly brave, new scientific research shows that humility usually walks hand in hand with courage. Many people have the experience of growing up in one set of circumstances and then finding themselves in a different set of circumstances as they grow up and start life on their own. If that's a familiar story to you, you also know what it's like to go back to the old
即 Hidden Brain Plus，我们将探讨谦逊的科学与心理学。这是一种在第一天往往被低估，但在长远来看却极受追捧的品质。虽然我们大多数人不会把谦逊的人与特别勇敢联系在一起，但新的科学研究表明，谦逊通常与勇气携手并进。许多人都有这样的经历：在一种环境中长大，然后在自己长大并开始独立生活时，发现自己身处另一种截然不同的环境中。如果你对这个故事感到熟悉，你也一定知道回到老
family home, the old neighborhood. They haven't changed much. But you? You find yourself miles apart, maybe galaxies apart, from the folks you knew as a kid. How do you respond to this? Do you go back to being the old you who fits in or the new you who doesn't? Darrell Van Tongren is a psychologist at Hope College in Michigan. He experienced the schism after he left his family home in Southern California and went off to college and graduate school. Darrell Van Tongren, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me.
家、回到老街是什么感觉。它们并没有多大变化。但是你呢？你会发现自己与儿时认识的人相隔甚远，甚至如同隔着星系。你该如何应对？你是回到那个墨守成规的老自己，还是去做那个格格不入的新自己？达雷尔·范汤格伦（Darrell Van Tongren）是密歇根州霍普学院的一名心理学家。在离开南加州的家乡去上大学和研究生院后，他也经历过这种撕裂。达雷尔·范汤格伦，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。
Tell me a little bit about your family of origin, Darrell. I understand you grew up in a conservative Christian household? I did, yeah. So growing up, I grew up in a working class family. My mom immigrated from the Netherlands when she was 10 or 11, married my dad who was a heavy diesel mechanic for Los Angeles County. And really the focus on my family was a lot about being together. We were a deeply religious family, very conservative, and really highly prioritized practical things. My dad was avid about cars and loved working on his cars. Did he spend a lot of time tinkering in his spare time? It sounds like he was working with his hands
达雷尔，跟我聊聊你的原生家庭吧。据我了解，你是在一个保守的基督教家庭长大的？是的，没错。我是在一个工人阶级家庭长大的。我妈妈在10岁或11岁时从荷兰移民过来，嫁给了我父亲，他曾是洛杉矶县的一名重型柴油机机械师。我的家庭真正关注的很多是如何在一起。我们是一个虔诚的宗教家庭，非常保守，并且高度重视实用性。我父亲酷爱汽车，喜欢修理他的汽车。他在业余时间花了很多时间摆弄车子吗？听起来他不仅在日常工作中用双手工作，
during his day job, but also with his hands in his spare time. Absolutely. So he had this, this prize possession, this 1972 Chevelle Super Sport, anytime he could, holidays, weekends, he was always tinkering on that card, trying to get it just right. Did he try and get his kids engaged in his passion? He did, sadly for him with not much success. So we didn't share his same passion for that car. Darrell and his siblings had other interests. They were all bookish in their own ways. They
在业余时间也用双手工作。绝对是的。他有一个珍视的宝贝，一辆1972年的雪佛兰Super Sport。只要一有机会，假期、周末，他总是围着那辆车捣鼓，试图把它调得恰到好处。他有没有试过让孩子们也参与到他的爱好中？他试过，但对她来说遗憾的是，并没有取得多大成功。所以我们对那辆车没有和他一样的热情。达雷尔和他的兄弟姐妹有其他的兴趣。他们以各自的方式都爱书如命，
all went on to college, the first in their immediate family to do so. Darrell continued on to graduate school. And as he became highly educated, he felt more and more removed from his working-class roots. It was challenging in many regards. When I went to graduate school, I felt out of place because, you know, I was in situations and with people who were much, you know, much more educated than my family was. You know, we would be at cocktail parties talking about things we had read and presumably sharing experiences we thought we all had as children that I didn't have. And then going back home, I felt like I couldn't fit in either because here I was trying to
他们都上了大学，是直系亲属中第一批上大学的人。达雷尔继续读了研究生。随着他受到的教育程度越来越高，他感觉自己与工人阶级根基的距离越来越远。在许多方面这都充满了挑战。当我读研究生时，我感到很不自在，因为你知道，我所处的环境和接触的人，比我的家人受过的教育要得多。你知道，我们在鸡尾酒会上谈论我们读过的事情，本以为大家作为孩子时都有过这些共同经历，但我并没有。然后回到家，我也觉得自己融入不进去，因为我在这里试图
be this budding intellectual, cultivated life of the mind, and it was much more pragmatic and let's talk about the car or let's talk about sports. And so I always felt kind of caught in between. Darrell tried to interest his dad in the things he was reading and learning. And I asked him hey you know what if we what if we read something you read something I'll read it we'll kind of connect on that and he you know he kind of said without missing a beat you know Darrell I literally have no interest in reading whatsoever.
成为一个初露头角的知识分子，追求精神层面的生活，而家里则更加实用主义，谈论的都是汽车或体育运动。所以我总觉得自己夹在中间进退维谷。达雷尔曾试图让父亲对他的阅读和学习内容感兴趣。我问他：“爸，要不这样，我们读点什么，你读点什么，我来读，我们在这上面交流一下。”他呢，不假思索地说：“达雷尔，说实话，我对阅读一点兴趣都没有。”
I literally have no interest in reading whatsoever. And I think at that moment, I felt this condescension. I felt this, you know, holier than thou attitude, like how could you not have any interest in reading? And I probably rolled my eyes to hold back some of my contempt. And that's when I really felt that difference. In time, Daryl came to see that he was part of the problem. When he looked down on his dad for not being interested in books, his own disdain placed a barrier between them.
“说实话，我对阅读一点兴趣都没有。”我想就在那一刻，我感到了这种居高自临。我感到了那种自以为是的态度，心想你怎么会连一点阅读兴趣都没有呢？我大概翻了个白眼，好掩饰我内心的一些轻蔑。也就是在那时，我真正感受到了那种差异。随着时间的推移，达雷尔开始意识到他自己也是问题的一部分。当他因为父亲对书本不感兴趣而看不起他时，他自己的这种鄙视在他们之间筑起了一道无形的壁垒。
I think one of the things I was doing that was impeding my relationship was I was really failing to take his perspective. So I was really centering what's going on in my life. I'm the one feeling hurt. Why doesn't he understand me? And not imagining, I wonder what it's like for my dad to have someone move far away. The rest of his kids were right there living in the same town. Here I am, I've left, I'm on the East Coast. Maybe he's feeling a little intimidated because he never graduated from college and here I am with an advanced degree. Are there ways that I'm speaking down to him? I'm acting in a condescending way and really failing to appreciate and take his perspective.
我想我当时阻碍我俩关系的一大行为，就是我真的没有站在他的角度去考虑问题。所以我把焦点完全放在自己生活的经历上。我是那个感到受伤的人。为什么他不理解我？而没有去想象：我的父亲看着孩子搬到远方去，会有什么感受呢？他的其他孩子都住在同一个镇上。而我呢，我离开了，我在东海岸。也许他会感到有点自卑，因为他从未大学毕业，而我却拥有高级学位。我是不是在用居高临下的语气跟他说话？我的行为是不是很傲慢，根本没有去体会和理解他的视角？
And once I realized that I had a part to play, I had to own up and take responsibility for what I was contributing to that relationship. It was only then that we could start making a turn into something better. Darrell went on to become a psychologist. He started to study humility. But as the years passed, he noticed that it was one thing to learn about humility and another to practice it. One time he was being interviewed by a reporter who asked him an interesting question that involved Darryl's wife, Sarah.
一旦我意识到自己也有责任，我就必须正视并承担起我对这段关系的负面影响。直到那时，我们才开始扭转局面，向更好的方向发展。达雷尔后来成为了一名心理学家。他开始研究谦逊。但随着时间流逝，他发现学习谦逊是一回事，实践谦逊又是另一回事。有一次，他接受了一位记者的采访，记者问了他一个有趣的问题，这涉及达雷尔的妻子莎拉。
Yeah, so this reporter was covering some of my recent research on humility within romantic relationships. And she said, you know, I'm kind of curious, you know, because you're someone who studies humility, you know, how do you fare in your romantic relationship? You know, would your partner consider you? How humble would your partner consider you to be? So she said, you know, would you mind asking your wife how humble you are? So, oh, so happy, you know, I'm so excited to
好的，这位记者当时在报道我最近关于恋爱关系中谦逊的研究。她说：“你知道，我挺好奇的，既然你是一个研究谦逊的人，你在恋爱关系中表现得怎么样呢？你的伴侣会认为你……你的伴侣会觉得你有多谦逊？”所以她说：“你介不介意问问你妻子，你有多谦逊？”哦，太好了，你知道，我当时兴奋极了，
go collect the data and prove to the reporter and the rest of the world that obviously someone who studies humility must be extremely humble. So I come upstairs from this interview from the basement and I say, Sarah, on a scale of one to ten, how humble would you rate me? And she says one to ten, I think I'd rate you a four. And so I'm crestfallen because I think oh gosh, a four, you know, that's below the midpoint. And then she says, well wait a minute, is one high or low? So for a moment I think, well maybe she misunderstood and I'll still be above the midpoint. I say no, one is low and 10 is high. And she goes, yeah, four. Yeah, you're just a four. I'm wondering if you asked her how she reached
要去收集数据，向记者和全世界证明，显然一个研究谦逊的人一定极其谦逊。所以我从地下室的采访地点上楼，对莎拉说：“莎拉，如果一到十分，你觉得我可以打几分？”她说：“一到十分，我觉得我给你打四分。”我顿时垂头丧气，心想天哪，四分，这在中间值以下啊。然后她说：“等一下，一分是高还是低？”所以有一会儿我想，也许她误解了，那我应该还是在中间值以上。我说：“一分是低，十分是高。”她说：“对啊，四分。没错，你也就是个四分。”我在想，达雷尔，你有没有问过她是如何得出
this conclusion, Daryl. Obviously, this was very different from your own conclusion of yourself. I immediately got defensive about why she would rate me as a four. And she kind of quickly pointed out that this was a day where we had promised to go to the beach. she would rate me as a four. And she kind of quickly pointed out that, this was a day where we had promised to go to the beach. I promised that we would leave for the beach
这个结论的？这显然与你对自己的看法大相径庭。我立刻开始为她为什么给我打四分进行辩解。她随即指出，那天本来是我们承诺要去海滩的日子……她随后指出，那天本来是我们承诺要去海滩的日子。我承诺过我们去海滩
no later than 11, but even knowing that, I took an interview at 10 a.m. And I assured her it'll be 15 minutes tops. Well, this interview drug on 75, almost 90 minutes. So we're running late. My wife has already packed the lunches. She's packed the towels, packed the reading material. She's ready to go to the beach. I finally come up, we're already running late, wasting precious sunshine, parking spots. And then before I even ask her to rate me, I say, you know, would you mind driving the stuff out there to the beach? I'd like to run to the beach because I'm training for a marathon and need to get a run in today. And the beach is about seven miles away, you know, and I was thinking about seven mile run is what I was like to run to the beach because I'm training for a marathon and need to get a run in today and the beach is about Seven miles away, you know, and I was thinking about a seven mile run is what I was gonna put in anyway
不晚于11点，但明知如此，我还是接了上午10点的一场采访。我向她保证顶多15分钟。结果呢，这个采访拖了75分钟，甚至快90分钟了。所以我们时间不够了。我妻子已经打包好了午餐。她打包好了毛巾，打包好了阅读材料。她准备好去海滩了。我终于上楼了，我们已经迟到了，在浪费宝贵的阳光和停车位。然后在我甚至还没开口让她给我打分之前，我就说：“你知道的，你介不介意把东西开车运到海滩去？我想跑步去海滩，因为我在为马拉松做准备，今天得跑跑步。海滩离这儿大约七英里，你知道的，我一直在想七英里的跑步是我……”因为我在为马拉松做准备，今天得跑步，海滩距离这里
So would you mind you know after all that you've done Going the extra mile and taking it all out to the beach and I'll just meet you down there after I get my run in so looking back for was probably a pretty gracious and Compassionate response. It's probably higher than I deserved at the moment. And of course, at that point, you didn't quite see it, right? You hadn't quite sort of seen the context when you came up the stairs and asked her because you obviously expected her to give you an eight or a nine. That's exactly right.
大约有七英里，你知道的，我一直在想七英里跑是我无论如何都会跑的。所以你介不介意，在做了这一切之后，多跑一趟把东西都带到海滩去？我跑完步后就在那儿和你汇合。所以回想起来，打四分可能是一个相当宽容且富有同情心的回应。这可能比我当时应得的分数还要高。当然，在那一刻，你并没有完全意识到这一点，对吧？当你上楼问她时，你并没有看清当时的来龙去脉，因为你显然期待她给你打个八分或九分。完全正确。
It was still lost on me. Even as she's painting me this picture, I still am trying to marshal my defense for, well, on average, you know, on average, aren't I kind of a humble guy? Don't I usually take your feedback? Don't I usually listen to you? And her blood is boiling because she said, you're literally not listening to me right now. I'm giving you feedback and you're not being responsive. You're responding defensively. If anything, you're confirming that you're a four. It took Daryl some time to see things from his wife's point of view. In time, his experience dovetailed with one of his research findings.
我当时依然执迷不悟。甚至当她向我描绘这幅画面时，我还在试图为自己辩护：从平均来看，难道我不是一个挺谦虚的人吗？我难道不经常接受你的反馈吗？我难道不经常听取你的意见吗？她当时气得火冒三丈，说道：“你现在字面意义上就没在听我说话。我在给你反馈，而你却一点都不听取。你在为自己辩解。如果你非要说的话，你这正是在证实自己确实是个四分。”达雷尔花了一些时间才真正从妻子的角度看待问题。最终，他的这段经历与他的一项研究发现不谋而合。
When you are acting arrogantly, it can be hard to realize you're acting arrogantly. When we come back, the psychological drivers and benefits of humility. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Daryl Van Tongren studies the science of humility. Over many years, he has studied different kinds of humility and also the effects that humility can have in the workplace, in society, and in personal relationships.
当你表现得傲慢时，你很难意识到自己正在傲慢。稍后回来，我们将探讨谦逊的心理驱动因素和益处。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。达雷尔·范汤格伦研究谦逊的科学。多年来，他研究了各种形式的谦逊，以及谦逊在职场、社会和个人关系中产生的影响。
We sampled people who were in these ongoing romantic relationships and we asked them to rate how humble their partner was. And we also asked them things about their relationships such as how committed are you to your relationship, how satisfied, how much do you forgive your partner. And what we found was that people who had humble partners, they were actually more committed to these partners. And because of that commitment, they reported being more satisfied in their relationship and they were more likely to forgive their partner when their partner did something wrong. So really, humility is the signal for how you're likely to be treated
我们对处于长期恋爱关系中的人群进行了抽样调查，让他们评估自己的伴侣有多谦逊。我们还询问了他们关于恋爱关系的问题，比如你对这段关系的承诺有多深、有多满意、你有多大程度会原谅你的伴侣。我们发现，拥有谦逊伴侣的人，实际上对这些伴侣更加忠诚。正因为这份忠诚，他们报告说对自己的恋爱关系更加满意，并且当伴侣做错事时，他们也更有可能原谅伴侣。所以实际上，谦逊是你可能如何被对待的一个信号。
in a relationship with someone else. And what that elicits from us is the strong sense of commitment that really enriches our relationships. And you found that this might be the case not just with established romantic couples, but even people considering getting into a relationship. You ran a study once using dating profiles.
在与他人的关系中。而这从我们身上唤起的是一种强烈的责任感，它确实丰富了我们的亲密关系。你发现，不仅在稳定的恋爱伴侣中可能是这样，甚至对于正在考虑建立恋爱关系的人来说也是如此。你曾经用约会资料做过一项研究。
Tell me about that work. So with this study, we brought participants in the lab and we showed them different mock dating profiles. And one was written rather arrogantly and one was written humbly. We had another version where they got feedback about the participant's personality personality including their humility or their arrogance. And in both situations people really rated more favorably the
跟我讲讲那项工作。在这项研究中，我们将参与者带到实验室，向他们展示了不同的模拟约会资料。其中一份写得相当傲慢，另一份写得很谦虚。我们还有另一个版本，他们会收到关于参与者个性的反馈，包括他们的谦逊或傲慢。在这两种情况下，人们对……的评价都明显更好。
profile that was humbler. So they wanted to be with the person who had the humble dating profile. They were more willing to want to meet that person, share their own profile, or even share their phone number to connect with this person outside of the study. Hmm. There's a great irony here, Daryl, because of course when you think about the way people fill out their dating profiles,
更谦虚的个人资料。所以他们更想和拥有谦虚约会资料的人在一起。他们更愿意去见那个人，分享自己的资料，甚至分享自己的电话号码以便在研究之外与这个人联系。嗯。这里有一个巨大的讽刺，达雷尔，因为当然，当你想到人们填写约会资料的方式时，
this is not the advice they follow. No, right. Most people want to put forth their most narcissistic self, right? It's the shirtless photo, right? The, you know, them on a boat or with a lot of money. But if you're thinking about a long-term committed relationship, the ones that are the best are not the ones with the narcissists who are the life of the party because they're putting other people down. Because that sours really quickly. Eventually, you're the person they target and put down. Long-term, committed relationships, those are going to thrive on a bedrock of humility.
这并不是他们遵循的建议。没错。大多数人想展现他们最自恋的自我，对吧？光着膀子的照片，对吧？他们坐在船上或带着很多钱的照片。但如果你考虑的是长期的承诺关系，最好的关系绝对不是那些自恋者、派对灵魂人物的关系，因为他们总是贬低别人。因为这种关系很快就会变味。最终，你就会成为他们针对和贬低的目标。长期的、承诺的关系，这些都需要建立在谦逊的基石上。
You've also looked at relationships when either both partners are humble or only one partner is humble. What do you find? Yeah, so both with first-time parents and with people who are in these ongoing relationships, what we found is that when both partners are humble, it really helps them in these critical periods of stress. So we had one study where we recruited participants during their last trimester before birth and then we tested them again after the child was born. A very stressful time. And if both partners are humble, they reported less depression, less stress, but only when both partners were humble. In another study, we brought participants in the lab and we had them argue about an area of contentious disagreement, kind of an ongoing argument in their relationship for nine minutes. And while they did, we had them hooked up to blood pressure cuffs. And what we found was if both partners were humble, they actually had a better physiological response, lower kind of blood pressure reactions to being
你还研究过当双方伴侣都很谦逊，或者只有一方伴侣谦逊时的关系。你发现了什么？是的，无论是对于初为人父母的人，还是对于处于这些长期关系中的人，我们发现，当双方伴侣都表现得谦逊时，这在充满压力的关键时期对他们大有帮助。我们曾做过一项研究，在参与者怀孕的最后三个月招募了他们，然后在孩子出生后对他们进行了再次测试。这是一个压力极大的时期。如果双方伴侣都很谦逊，他们报告的抑郁感更少、压力更小，但前提是双方伴侣都很谦逊。在另一项研究中，我们将参与者带到实验室，让他们就一个有争议的分歧领域进行争论，也就是他们关系中持续存在的争论，持续九分钟。在他们争论的同时，我们给他们戴上了血压袖带。我们发现，如果双方伴侣都很谦逊，他们的生理反应实际上更好，面对这种充满压力的分歧时血压反应更低。但同样，这只存在于那些双方伴侣都很谦逊的伴侣中，因为如果一方谦逊而另一方傲慢，你就会面临被剥削的风险。那么在那些双方不匹配的情况下会发生什么呢？在不匹配的情况下，谦逊实际上可能会带来负面影响，对吧？
in this stressful disagreement. But again, it's only present in those couples when both partners are humble, because if one is humble and one is arrogant, you run the risk of being exploited. And so what happens in those situations when you have a mismatch? In the mismatch, there can actually be a downside to being humble, right?
在这次压力重重的争执中。但再次强调，这种情况只存在于双方都很谦逊的情侣身上，因为如果一方谦逊而另一方傲慢，你就会面临被利用的风险。那么在那些存在不匹配的情况下会发生什么呢？在不匹配的情况下，谦逊实际上也可能有消极的一面，对吧？
Because you're the one who's picking up the slack, you're caring for the child more, or you're the one conceding to the argument, and those people's outcomes are poorer. Now the same thing obviously happens in work settings. You know, all over the world, people prefer to work with partners who are humble, and no one likes to work with someone who is a know-it-all. Can you tell me a little bit about this work? What does the research show about the role of humility in the workplace?
因为你是那个收拾烂摊子的人，你更多地照顾孩子，或者你是那个在争论中妥协的人，而这些人的结局往往更差。现在，这种情况显然也会发生在工作环境中。你知道，在世界各地，人们更愿意与谦逊的合作伙伴共事，没有人喜欢和万事通共事。能跟我讲讲这项工作吗？研究表明谦逊在职场中扮演什么角色？
Yeah, there's a big literature of research on humility in leadership and in the workplace. And what they find is that people are much more willing to work for humble leaders. There's higher productivity, more employee engagement, employee satisfaction. Teams are more creative. We also see that humility operates a little bit like a social contagion. So if the leader is humble, it spreads to the workers, spreads to the teams. And it has this cascading effect where everyone in the organization expresses more humility. So we've talked a bit about this idea that's broadly under the umbrella of relational humility.
是的，关于领导力和职场中谦逊的研究文献非常丰富。研究发现，人们更愿意为谦逊的领导工作。生产力更高，员工参与度更高，员工满意度也更高。团队更具创造力。我们还发现，谦逊的运作方式有点像一种社会传染。因此，如果领导是谦逊的，它就会蔓延到员工身上，蔓延到团队中。它会产生这种连锁反应，组织中的每个人都表现出更多的谦逊。我们已经讨论了广义上属于关系谦逊范畴的这个概念。
And I want to pivot now to a different kind of humility. I understand that some years ago you and your wife moved to a new town and started spending time with another couple. And it gave you a window into the nature of another kind of humility that we've talked about on the show before. This would be intellectual humility. Tell me the story of your interaction with these new friends. So we moved to this town because I've got the job at Hope College and we're meeting this couple,
现在我想把话题转向另一种谦逊。据我了解，几年前你和妻子搬到一个新小镇，并开始与另一对夫妇交往。这让你得以一窥我们在节目中讨论过的另一种谦逊的本质。这就是智识谦逊。讲讲你与这几位新朋友交往的故事吧。我们搬到这个镇上是因为我在霍普学院找到了一份工作，我们遇到了这对夫妇，
really smart couple, very well traveled, very cultured, close friends of ours really. And as we're getting to know them more, here I am coming from a working class background, feeling very much out of my element. They start mentioning books that they've read or shows that they've watched, or maybe museums that they've interacted with and explored.
非常聪明的夫妇，见多识广，很有文化，实际上是我们很亲密的朋友。随着我们对他们了解的加深，我这个出身工人阶级背景的人，感觉非常不自在。他们开始提到他们读过的书、看过的节目，或者他们去过和探索过的博物馆。
And they ask, hey, Dara, have you read this book? Or you seen this show? And out of kind of insecurity and shame, I go, oh yeah, I've seen that. I've read that, I watched that. And really, I never had, I was lying about these things. And then they would, you know, talk to me and I'd spend the next 15 minutes feeling very uncomfortable having to fake my way through a conversation. Yeah. And one night I got home and I thought, you know, I'm just I'm just tired of that. I'm
然后他们问：“嘿，达雷尔，你读过这本书吗？或者你看过这个节目吗？”出于某种不安全感和羞耻感，我说：“哦，我看过。我读过，我看过。”实际上，我根本没看没读过，我在这些事情上撒了谎。然后他们就会，你知道的，跟我聊起来，而我接下来的15分钟都会感到非常不舒服，不得不硬着头皮把对话敷衍过去。是的。有一天我回到家，心想，你知道的，我真是……我真的是厌倦了。我
just going to stop doing that. And so what I what I started doing was the next time that happened, and they said, Hey, have you seen the show or read this book? I just flatly said, No, I haven't. I'm just tired of that. I'm just gonna stop doing that. And so what I started doing was the next time that happened and they said, hey, have you seen the show or read this book? I just flatly said, no, I haven't. And you would be surprised. They said, oh, you haven't read that book? They walked to the other room, they grabbed the book,
打算不再这么做了。所以，我开始做的是，下次遇到这种情况时，他们问：“嘿，你看过这个节目或者读过这本书吗？”我直接说：“没有，我没看过。”我真是……我真的是厌倦了。我打算不再这么做了。所以，我开始做的是，下次遇到这种情况时，他们问：“嘿，你看过这个节目或者读过这本书吗？”我直接说：“没有，我没看过。”你会感到惊讶的。他们说：“哦，你没读过这本书啊？”他们走到另一个房间，拿来那本书，
they loaned it to me, they said, you'd love it. And I'm like, oh my gosh, they didn't judge me? I just, now I get to read the book. Or they said, oh, you haven't watched the show? I'll send it to you via text. You all can watch it and we can discuss. And so once I realized I should stop faking what I didn't know and just be honest about what I didn't, it just opened up my world and now I could enjoy these things so much
把它借给我，说：“你会喜欢的。”我心想：“哦天哪，他们没有评判我？太好了，现在我可以读这本书了。”或者他们说：“哦，你没看过这个节目？我发信息给你。你们都可以看，然后我们一起讨论。”所以一旦我意识到我应该停止伪装自己不知道的事情，而是对不知道的事情保持诚意，我的世界就豁然开朗了，现在我可以尽情享受这些事情了。
more. Can you talk about the role of intellectual humility or the lack of intellectual humility in our public and social and even our media climate? Because I feel like when I see people on cable television, when I see round tables at conferences where people are on panels, there are very few people who actually say, I don't know the answer to this question. That's a really good question. It's beyond me. Yeah, it's sadly becoming so increasingly rare. And instead, what we have is we have a society and we have a culture in which certainty is rewarded, claiming that you know the absolute
你可以谈谈智识谦逊的作用，或者在我们的公共、社会甚至媒体环境中缺乏智识谦逊的现象吗？因为我觉得，当我看到有线电视上的嘉宾，当我看到会议上人们组成圆桌讨论小组时，极少有人会真正说：“我不知道这个答案。”这是一个非常好的问题。这超出了我的认知。是的，遗憾的是，这变得越来越罕见。相反，我们拥有的是一个社会和文化，在这个社会和文化中，确信会受到奖励，声称你知道绝对的
truth is rewarded. And sadly what's happening is we become unable or unwilling to interact with people with whom we disagree or who don't share ideologically similar viewpoints. And so between our unwillingness or inability to engage with people who differ from us and a very tailored algorithm for how we get our news if we're using our phone or our computer, we're just reinforced with the way I see the world has to be the way that everyone else sees the world. And if they don't, surely their way is far inferior to the way I see it. It's not just that people are want to speak with certainty, but we are also drawn to people who speak with certainty.
真理会受到奖励。可悲的是，发生的情况是我们变得无法或不愿意与那些与我们意见不一、或者在意识形态上与我们观点不相似的人进行互动。因此，介于我们不愿意或无法与不同观点的人交往，再加上如果我们使用手机或电脑获取新闻时的定制化算法，我们只会不断得到强化，即我看到世界的方式必须是所有人看到世界的方式。如果他们不是，那他们的看法肯定远不如我的看法。人们不仅希望带着确信说话，而且我们也被那些说话带有确信的人所吸引。
That when someone says they're hesitant, they say, I don't know, this is beyond my pay grade, you know, I'll have to get back to you on the answer. That person looks less qualified, less smart than the person who says, I know the answer and here it is. That's exactly right. And if you think about it, you know, the core of the scientific enterprise, the root of it should be a curiosity of saying, I don't know, but I'd like to go find out and I'm going to gather the sufficient empirical evidence to do so. But even within the academy, we've become increasingly more rewarded for coming up with our pet theory, defending our
当有人表现出犹豫，说“我不知道，这超出了我的能力范围，你知道，我得查查再给你答复”时，这个人看起来不如那个说“我知道答案，答案在这里”的人那么有资格、那么聪明。完全正确。如果你仔细想想，你知道，科学事业的核心，它的根源应该是一种好奇心，即说“我不知道，但我很想去探究，并且我会收集足够的实证证据来做到这一点”。但即使在学术界，我们也越来越因为提出自己钟爱的理论、向其他可能暗示我们错误的审稿人或学者捍卫
pet theory to other reviewers or academics who might suggest we're wrong, and then trying to get tenure by proving to everybody that we're right, and then viciously defending it when people come up with new data that suggests we might be wrong. There's something about our fear of uncertainty, our fear of the loss of control, or our inability to live where we don't have all the answers, that does make us naturally drawn to people who project that type of confidence and charisma that they have all the answers. So, one other way in which we do not respond with appropriate humility is something known as the humble brag. It's become something
自己钟爱的理论而获得更多奖励，然后试图通过向所有人证明我们是正确的来获得终身教职，而在人们提出表明我们可能是错误的新数据时，又进行疯狂的辩护。我们对不确定性的恐惧、对失去控制的恐惧，或者我们无法生活在没有所有答案的环境中的无能，确实让我们本能地被那些散发着拥有所有答案的自信和个人魅力的人所吸引。所以，我们未能以适当的谦逊做出回应的另一种方式被称为“谦虚地炫耀”（humblebrag）。我认为，这已经成为了社交媒体上的一个迷因（meme）。但达雷尔，你能谈谈这个概念吗，就是我们用这些非常聪明的谦虚炫耀来假装谦逊？
of a meme, I think, on social media. But can you talk about this idea, Daryl, that we pretend to be humble with these very clever humble brags? Yeah. So the humble brag is a way of expressing publicly that we feel very grateful for something while you're on your brand new yacht or showing off your new car or winning this prestigious promotion, or talking about your salary. And you know, I'm just deeply grateful I didn't earn this. And so it can kind of take two flavors. So one flavor is showcasing your great achievement in a way that you're
是的。所以谦虚地炫耀是一种公开表达的方式，即当你在你的全新游艇上、或者炫耀你的新车、赢得这令人艳羡的晋升、或谈论你的薪水时，你对某事感到非常感激。而且你知道，“我只是深深地感激，我并不配拥有这个”。所以它大致可以分为两类。第一类是以一种完全没有对其他人表现出感激、也没有承认可能是其他人促成了你取得这一成就的方式来展示你的伟大成就；
really not demonstrating any gratitude towards other people or acknowledgement for other people's credit that might have led you to get there. And the other is to solicit from other people even more affirmation about how great your situation might be by pretending to falsely be modest, like, oh, this old thing, oh, you know, it's totally fine.
另一种则是通过假装谦虚来从其他人那里索取更多的肯定，以证明你的处境有多好，比如：“哦，这件旧东西，哦，你知道的，这完全没什么。”
Yeah, I'm so disappointed with myself that it took me three hours to finish this marathon. Yeah, that's exactly right. And everyone who finished the marathon in four or running marathons are like, oh man, what does that mean for me? One reason humility can be hard to practice is that most of us have blind spots when it comes to our view of ourselves. With his students, Darrell conducts an exercise that reveals this blind spot.
“是的，我对花三个小时才跑完马拉松感到非常失望。”是的，完全正确。而那些用四个小时跑完马拉松或经常跑马拉松的人就会想：“天哪，那对我意味着什么？”谦逊难以践行的一个原因是，我们大多数人在看待自己时都有盲点。达雷尔通过与学生的互动，进行了一项揭示这种盲点的练习。
Yeah, so I hand out index cards to my students and I have them rate themselves compared to the average student at our college on zero to a hundred percent. How intelligent are you? How attractive are you? How sociable are you? And almost without fail fail everybody rates themselves on average between the 65th and 70th percentile. Yeah, exactly you get it. So everyone kind of sees themselves as above average. And so you know once they once that kind of sinks in they laugh but then I follow up and I say but most of you actually think that's true. Right? Most of you actually think that you're above average, even though half of us have to be below average. And so what
是的，我给我的学生分发索引卡，让他们在0到100%的范围内，将自己与我们学院的平均学生进行比较评分。你有多聪明？你有多迷人？你有多合群？几乎无一例外，每个人给自己的评分都在第65到第70百分位之间。是的，完全正确，你懂的。所以每个人都认为自己高于平均水平。因此，你知道，一旦这种认知深入人心，他们就会笑，但我接着追问：“但你们大多数人真的认为那是真的，对吧？你们大多数人真的认为自己高于平均水平，尽管我们中有一半人必须低于平均水平。”所以这
it demonstrates two things. One is what's called the above average effect, right? So, or the better than average effect. Most of us think that we're above average. And the second thing it demonstrates is even when we're given feedback that we're biased, we have this bias blind spot. And even when we're given feedback, we may acknowledge that we're biased. We have this bias blind spot. And even when we're given feedback, we may acknowledge that we're biased, but we're not as biased as other people. So we're even biased about our own bias. There's another type of humility that you have studied, and you call it cultural humility. How would you define this term, Daryl? So cultural humility is our ability to not view our own cultural way of life as superior, to engage other people across cultural differences with curiosity, with respect, and with a sense
说明了两点。一是所谓的“高于平均水平效应”，也就是“优于平均效应”。我们大多数人都认为自己高于平均水平。第二点它说明了，即使在我们得到自己有偏见的反馈时，我们也有这种“偏见盲点”。即使我们得到了反馈，我们可能会承认自己有偏见，但我们认为自己没有别人那么偏见。所以我们甚至对自己的偏见本身也抱有偏见。你还研究了另一种类型的谦逊，你称之为文化谦逊。达雷尔，你会如何定义这个术语？文化谦逊是指我们能够不将自己的文化生活方式视为优越，以好奇、尊重和平等感跨越文化差异与他人交往，并愿意从其他文化差异中学习，将文化多样性视为一种力量，而不是对我们生存方式的威胁。
of equality, and then a willingness to want to learn from other cultural differences and to view cultural diversity as a strength rather than a threat to our way of being. I understand that you were challenged some years ago to see things from a different perspective when a student at your college came to you in some distress. What did she tell you, Daryl? She came to my office and she was a young African-American woman who said, you know, the college is considering arming its security officers. And, you know, I'm quite concerned about this. A number of my friends are very concerned that we're going to be disproportionately negatively affected by this. You know, we learned in social psychology
据我了解，几年前，当你们学院的一名学生满腹愁容地来找你时，你曾受到挑战，要求你从不同的角度看问题。她对你说了什么，达雷尔？她来到我的办公室，她是一名年轻的非裔美国女性，她说：“你知道，学院正在考虑给安保人员配备武器。而且，你知道的，我对此相当担忧。我的许多朋友都非常担心我们将因此受到不成比例的负面影响。你知道，我们在社会心理学中了解到……”关于偏见和刻板印象在这些类型情况下的运作方式。我非常担心。她说：“你知道的，我甚至害怕跟你分享这些。你是一个白人男性教授。我对你感到畏惧。向你表达这些担忧我都觉得紧张。但我想既然我们在课堂上讨论过这个，也许你是一个很好的倾听起点。”我深受感动。我们俩都潸然泪下。我们有了一个分享的时刻。而真正从中涌现出来的是，我认真对待了她所说的话。我跟进了一些行政人员。
about the way that prejudice and stereotyping plays out in these types of situations. And I'm very concerned. And she said, you know, I'm scared to even share this with you. You're a white male professor. I'm intimidated by you. I'm nervous to even express these concerns to you. But I figured because we talked about it in class, maybe you would be a good place to start. I was so touched by this. We both broke down into tears. We had a moment of sharing. And really what came out of that was I took seriously the things that she said. I followed up with some administrators.
并且我并不是说我和她独自一人是他们没有做出这个决定的原因，但我非常高兴能在几个月后向她汇报，你知道的，事实上他们已经决定不再推行。我非常感谢她的诚实和分享她的经历。需要明确的是，这最初并不是你自己的担忧。所以在她向你提出这一点之前，并不是说你整晚都在担心
And I'm not saying that I or she alone was the reason they did not make this decision. But I was very pleased to be able to report back to her, you know, a few months later that they in fact had decided not to move forward. And I was very grateful for her honesty and sharing her experience. Now to be clear, this was not a concern that you had initially had yourself. So until she brought this to you, it wasn't like you were staying up at night worried
学校里的安保人员会配备武器。是的，确实如此。对我来说，这更像是一种抽象的担忧，比如“嗯，我真的不认为这是一个好主意。研究表明这并不太好，但我算老几，我什么也不能说？我还是过我自己的日子吧。”绝对是这样的。她通过分享她自己对这个问题的焦虑和恐惧，将其提升为一个值得关注的问题。但当然，你所做的并不是简单地通过“你是否也分享她的担忧”这个镜头来过滤她的担忧，你实际上是设身处地为她着想了。
that the security officers were being armed at your school. Right, that's right. For me, it was more of this abstract like, well, I don't really think this is a good idea. The research suggests this isn't very good, but who am I to say anything? I'm just going to go on with my day. That's absolutely right. She elevated it to a concern by sharing her own anxiety, her own fear around this issue. But of course, what you did is you didn't just simply filter her concerns through the lens of whether you shared her concerns You actually put yourself in her shoes
你们学校的安全保卫人员开始武装起来。是的，没错。对我来说，这更像是一种抽象的概念，比如，嗯，我真的不觉得这是个好主意。研究表明这并不是很好，但我算老几，怎么能指手画脚呢？我还是过我自己的日子吧。完全正确。她通过分享自己对这个问题的焦虑和恐惧，将这件事提升为一个值得关注的问题。但当然，你所做的并不仅仅是通过你是否也同样担忧的视角来过滤她的担忧，你实际上是设身处地为她着想了
And I think very often what happens in a lot of these situations is is that when we hear about someone's concerns We ask ourselves are those concerns the same as my concerns So if we share those concerns we say well, of course the concerns are legitimate and we should do something with it But if we don't share those concerns, we often tend to say, well, they must not be real or they can't be real or they just made up. And I think what you're saying here, Dharul, is that sometimes even if something doesn't make sense to us, cultural humility asks us to accept that they can be a real concern to someone else. That's exactly right. And in that moment, it was so deeply moving to see how vulnerable
我想很多时候在许多这类情况下发生的事情是，当我们听到某人的担忧时，我们会问自己：这些担忧和我的担忧是一样的吗？如果我们有相同的担忧，我们就会说，当然这些担忧是合情合理的，我们应该采取行动。但如果我们没有这些担忧，我们往往会说，它们一定不是真的，或者它们不可能是真的，或者它们只是凭空捏造的。我想你在这里所说的，达雷尔，是有时即使某事对我们来说没有意义，文化谦逊也要求我们接受它对别人来说可能是真正的担忧。完全正确。而在那一刻，看到她是如此脆弱，看到她受此影响如此之深，这深深地打动了我，使我不得不承认，这远比我最初想象的要严重得多，而且它关乎的不仅仅是我自己，还有更多的人。你知道，我在思考“幼稚现实主义”这个概念，这是心理学中一个强有力的概念，即我们都认为我们看待世界的方式就是世界实际的模样。而这需要付出一番努力去说：是的，我对世界有我的一套看法和担忧，但如果你有不同的看法或不同的担忧，这并不会让你的看法或担忧变得
she was and how affected she was by this, that I couldn't help but be compelled to see that this was much more of a concern than I had originally thought it to be and for many more people than just myself. You know I'm thinking about the idea of naive realism which is a powerful idea in psychology which is that we all believe that the way we see the world is the way the world actually is. And it takes something of an act of effort to say, yes I have my set of views of the world and I have my concerns, but if you have a different view or a different set of concerns, that doesn't make your views or your concerns
微不足道或错误。对，这种思维方式深深地烙印在我们的心理结构中，因为你开始问自己：好吧，如果我在这一点上是错的，即使是一件小事，我还可能在哪些方面是错的？如果你把这一点无限放大，你就会开始问自己：好吧，如果我在这一点上是错的，即使是一件小事，我还可能在哪些方面是错的？如果你把这一点无限放大，你就会开始思考：好吧，我是不是在那些深层的、重大的存在主义问题上弄错了，
insignificant or mistaken. Right, and that way of thinking is so baked in to our psychological architecture, because you start asking yourself, well, if I'm wrong about this, and even if it's something small, what else might I be wrong about? And if you extrapolate that up higher and higher and higher, you start asking yourself, well, if I'm wrong about this, and even if it's something small, what else might I be wrong about? And if you extrapolate that up higher and higher and higher, you start thinking about, well, am I wrong about, you know, these big, deep existential questions
比如我如何度过我人生的意义，或者我死后会发生什么，或者生命的意义可能是什么？考虑我们可能会出错，这一切都非常令人不安，尽管所有证据都表明我们大多数人可能确实都错了。稍后回来，我们将探讨实践谦逊以及在面对人生最深奥的问题时接受我们所不知晓之事的挑战。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
about, you know, how I'm spending my life's purpose or what happens to me after I die or what the meaning of life might be? And all of those are very deeply unsettling to consider that we might be wrong, although all the evidence suggests that most of us probably are wrong. When we come back, practicing humility and the challenge of accepting what we don't know, when it comes to the deepest questions of life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
达雷尔·范汤格伦是霍普学院的一名心理学家。他是《谦逊：把自己从自恋世界的陷阱中解放出来》（Humble: Free Yourself from the Traps of a Narcissistic World）一书的作者。达雷尔，几年前，你和妻子正前往一家餐厅进行一次美好的约会，这时发生了一件非常戏剧性的事情。请给我描绘一下那天晚上发生了什么。我们在去吃晚饭的路上遇到红灯，非常突然且意料之外地，我们目睹了就在我们眼前发生的一场相当严重的交通事故。两辆车相撞，其中一辆车翻进了沟里。我立即把车停在路边，让妻子报警，而我则跑下去试图
Daryl Van Tongren is a psychologist at Hope College. He's the author of Humble, Free Yourself from the Traps of a Narcissistic World. Daryl, some years ago, you and your wife were heading to dinner for a nice date when something very dramatic happened. Paint me a picture of what happened that evening. So we're at a stoplight on our way to dinner, and we witness very suddenly and unexpectedly a rather severe car accident right in front of us. Two cars collide and one of the cars rolls into a ditch. I immediately pull the car over and ask my wife to call 911 while I run down and try
协助其他人把那辆翻车的司机和乘客救出来，而我则跑下去试图协助其他人把那辆翻车的司机和乘客救出来。最后，当警察和紧急救援人员到达时，他们要求每个人都重新叙述他们所看到的情况。于是每个人都分别接受了采访。在我们提供完目击证词后，我们回到车里，开车去吃晚饭。正当我和妻子回忆我们所看到的情景时，你知道的，我们中的一个人说：
to assist the other folks who are getting the driver and passengers out of the car over and ask my wife to call 911 while I run down and try to assist the other folks who are getting the driver and passengers out of the car that had rolled over. Eventually, when the police and emergency personnel came, they asked everyone to recount what they had seen. And so everyone was interviewed separately. And after we had given our eyewitness testimony, we headed back to the car and drove off to dinner. And as my wife and I were recounting what we had seen, you know, one of us said,
去协助其他人把司机和乘客从车里救出来，然后请我妻子拨打911，而我则跑过去试图协助其他人把司机和乘客从那辆翻倒的车里救出来。最后，当警察和紧急救援人员到达时，他们要求每个人重新叙述他们所看到的情况。于是每个人都接受了单独的采访。在我们提供完目击证词后，我们回到车里，开车去吃晚餐。正当我和妻子在回想我们所看到的事情时，你知道，我们其中的一个人说，
goodness, I can't believe that the pickup truck ran through the red light and hit the van causing it to roll into the ditch. And the other one of us said, no, no, no, it was the van that ran the red light and hit the pickup truck. And so we started this argument about which car was at fault and which car hit the other. And we were two people with plain view of what was going on with two totally discrepant accounts of reality that had unfolded just in front of us. How did you settle this argument? Well, we pulled the car over, we went to a Starbucks, we got the salt and pepper shakers and the sugar packets, and we recreated the accident scene right there on the table. And in fact, it was still a point of contention where we decided one of us had to be wrong, and so we just decided to leave it just as that.
天哪，我真不敢相信那辆皮卡车居然闯红灯，撞上了面包车，导致面包车翻进沟里。而我们中的另一个人说，不，不，不，是面包车闯红灯撞了皮卡车。于是我们开始争论到底哪辆车违章，哪辆车撞了哪辆车。我们两个人都亲眼目睹了当时发生的一切，但对刚刚在眼前展开的现实却有着完全截然不同的说法。你们是怎么解决这个争论的？嗯，我们把车停在路边，去了一家星巴克，拿了盐瓶、胡椒瓶和糖包，就在桌上重现了事故现场。事实上，这仍然是一个争论点，直到我们决定其中一个人肯定是错的，所以我们干脆决定就此作罢。
So, of course, what this shows is that perhaps one of the first steps to humility is to recognize that the way we see the world might not actually be the way the world is. Can you talk about this idea, Daryl? Yeah. So, most of the time, I think what we do is we interpret the world through a set of schemas or through a lens in which it confirms our pre-existing beliefs. So even when we encounter mixed evidence or neutral evidence, we tend to think that it affirms the way we want the world to be. And usually we're looking for feedback that either
所以，当然，这表明谦逊的第一步也许是认识到我们看待世界的方式可能并不真的是世界原本的样子。达里尔，你能谈谈这个想法吗？好的。所以，大多数时候，我认为我们所做的是通过一套图式或某种视角来解释世界，以证实我们原有的信念。因此，即使当我们遇到复杂的证据或中立的证据时，我们也倾向于认为它证实了我们希望世界成为的样子。通常我们都在寻找这样的反馈：要么
makes us feel better, verifies our pre-existing beliefs, or otherwise enhances our ego or way of seeing the world. In some ways this is a subtler form of humility because I think when most people think about being humble, they think about you know not boasting or not talking arrogantly. Most of us don't imagine that you know when we look out of the world and we see the world and we tell other people what we're seeing, that that could also in some ways involve an element of arrogance because we assume, again, that the way we see the world is the way the world actually is. Right.
让我们感觉更好，验证我们预先存在的信念，或者以其他方式增强我们的自我或看世界的方式。在某些方面，这是一种更微妙的谦逊形式，因为我认为当大多数人想到谦逊时，他们想到的是不吹嘘或不傲慢地说话。我们大多数人不会想象，当我们审视这个世界，看到这个世界，并告诉别人我们看到了什么时，这在某些方面也可能包含着一种傲慢，因为我们再次假设，我们看世界的方式就是世界实际的对吧。
And we can't imagine that there might be another way in which we could see the world, another set of perspectives that we haven't even considered. Because surely the way I see it is the way it has to be, and my way has to be the right way. You know, I'm reminded of the study that Lee Ross conducted at Stanford University many decades ago. He brought Israeli students into the lab and Arab students into the lab, or at least supporters of the Israeli and Arab causes, and he showed them clips from major news networks and he asked them to count the number of anti-Israel and anti-Arab references in the news clips. And he found that the Israelis counted an enormous number of anti-Israel
而且我们无法想象可能还有另一种看待世界的方式，还有我们甚至没有考虑过的一套观点。因为毫无疑问，我看到的方式必然是它应该有的方式，我的方式一定是对的。你知道，我想起了几十年前李·罗斯在斯坦福大学进行的一项研究。他把以色列学生和阿拉伯学生带进实验室，或者至少是以色列和阿拉伯事业的支持者，他给他们看主要新闻网络的剪辑，并要求他们数一数新闻剪辑中反以色列和反阿拉伯的言论数量。他发现以色列人计算出了数量惊人的反以色列
references in the news clips and the Arabs, looking at the very same news clips, counted an enormous number of anti-Arab references. And of course what this shows is that we can all be looking at the same thing, but draw completely different conclusions and each be convinced that the way we see the world has to be the correct way to see the world. That's absolutely right. And that coincides and confirms a lot of other research that has examined the same type of behavior, whether it's sports teams that are counting the number of fouls committed during a contentious sporting contest, or the number of so-called points scored by presidential candidates during a debate,
新闻剪辑中的言论和阿拉伯人看着完全相同的剪辑，计算出数量惊人的反阿拉伯言论。当然，这表明我们都可以看同一件事，却得出完全不同的结论，并且各自确信我们看世界的方式一定是最正确的方式。完全正确。这与许多其他研究不谋而合，并且证实了这些研究，这些研究考察了同类型的行为，无论是运动队计算在激烈的体育比赛中犯规的次数，还是总统候选人在辩论中所谓的得分数，
each walking away thinking that my candidate won. We both look at the same objective evidence, but we do so rather subjectively in a way that reinforces the way we want the world to be rather than the way the world actually is. And of course, this is not happening just at an interpersonal level. When I think about the study that Lee Ross conducted, I'm also now reminded of what's actually happening in the Middle East right now and how on a much larger scale the same forces are at play in terms of geopolitical conflict, not just interpersonal
每个人离开时都认为我的候选人赢了。我们都看着相同的客观证据，但我们的做法相当主观，其方式是为了强化我们所希望的世界，而不是世界实际的样子。当然，这不仅发生在我们的人际交往层面。当我想到李·罗斯进行的那项研究时，我现在也想到了中东目前实际正在发生的事情，以及在更大规模上，同样的动力如何在在地缘政治冲突中发挥作用，而不仅仅是人际冲突。
conflict. Right. And what I really think this does is it underscores that my own individual humility contributes to my societal humility, which contributes to a larger national or worldwide humility. And we need this humility on so many different levels. I can only work on myself, but working myself can also contribute to making my community, my society in this world a more humble and hopefully more objectively fair place to live. And presumably the reverse is also true. You know, my arrogant confidence in my own vision and my own sense of reality probably contributes to the way my society sees things and my nation sees things. Right, because if we circle back to that research about humility is most beneficial when both partners are humble. And in a dyad, if one partner is arrogant and the other is humble, the humble partner pays the price. If you ratchet up
冲突。对。而我真正认为这样做的是，它强调了我个人的谦逊有助于我的社会谦逊，这有助于实现更大规模的国家或世界范围内的谦逊。我们需要这种不同层面的谦逊。我只能改变自己，但改变自己也有助于让我的社区、我的社会和这个世界成为一个更加谦逊、更有希望在客观上更公平的居住地。据推测，反之亦然。你知道，我对自己的愿景和现实感的傲慢自信可能会助长我的社会和国家看待事物的方式。没错，如果我们回到关于谦逊的研究，当双方都谦逊时，谦逊最有利。在一个双人组合中，如果一方傲慢而另一方谦逊，谦逊的一方就会付出代价。如果你加剧
your arrogance, I'm gonna likely do the same because I don't want to have to be the one to pay the price. So if I become increasingly more arrogant, other people will too, and it becomes this arms race for arrogance, and then we slowly start losing some of the integrity and civility in our culture. You see that a key part of humility is being honest with ourselves and others about our flaws and limitations, especially when we haven't lived up to our own values. Some time ago, the actor and podcaster Dax Shepard talked about how he had relapsed into addiction. He had been hiding it from his family, from friends, from his audience, and he had promised his audience to be authentic with them. When he called a friend, the friend gave him some advice.
你的傲慢，我也可能会这样做，因为我不想成为付出代价的人。因此，如果我变得越来越傲慢，其他人也会如此，这就变成了傲慢的军备竞赛，然后我们慢慢开始失去文化中的一些正直和文明。你看，谦逊的一个关键部分是对自己和他人诚实地面对自己的缺点和局限性，尤其是当我们没有达到自己的价值观时。不久前，演员兼播客达克斯·谢泼德谈到他如何再次陷入毒瘾。他一直向家人、朋友和观众隐瞒这件事，并且他曾承诺对观众保持真实。当他打电话给一位朋友时，朋友给他一些建议。
I want to play you a clip of what Dak said. And he says, you know, your number one character defect is your arrogance. You think you're so much smarter than everybody. And he said, and I know it because I suffer from the same one, which is true. I never thought I'm not an addict, but I thought I'm a smart enough addict to do this and be smarter than it and come up with a bulletproof game plan. And he said, you know, it's your number one character defect in that unfortunately I know the antidote to it, which is humility.
我想放一段达克说的话给你听。他说，你知道，你性格上最大的缺陷就是你的傲慢。你觉得自己比所有人都聪明。他说，我知道这一点，因为我也遭受着同样的痛苦，这是真的。我从来没想过我不是瘾君子，但我以为我是一个足够聪明的瘾君子，可以做到这一点，比它更聪明，并想出一个万无一失的游戏计划。他说，你知道，这是你性格上最大的缺陷，不幸的是我知道它的解药，那就是谦逊。
And there would be nothing more humbling for you than to ultimately tell everyone, period. And that was terrifying. So first off, Daryl, hats off to Dak Shepard for acknowledging he had a problem and doing something about it. That took real courage. But I also think what he just said is really true. One reason we turn away from humility is that it can be terrifying.
没有什么比最终把一切都告诉所有人更让你感到谦卑的了，句号。这太可怕了。首先，达里尔，向达克斯·谢泼德致敬，他承认自己有问题并为此采取了行动。这需要真正的勇气。但我也认为他刚才所说的是千真万确的。我们拒绝谦逊的原因之一是它可能非常可怕。
Yeah. I think that there's this honest vulnerability that comes with humility. If it really is seeing ourselves, strength and weakness, right? The parts of ourselves that we love, but also the parts of ourselves where we might feel a little bit more ashamed. That is very vulnerable. That is very scary to admit. We may not be the overly glowing representation
是的。我认为谦逊伴随着一种诚实的脆弱性。如果它真的是在审视我们自己，无论是优点还是缺点，对吧？我们爱自己的部分，但也是我们可能感到羞耻的部分。这是非常脆弱的。承认这一点是非常可怕的。我们可能不是那种光芒四射的代表
of ourselves we hold in our own minds. And we are flawed. We are limited. We are these bounded creatures who hurt each other and who are less noble than we like to imagine. And so the honesty of humility is terrifying and liberating. And that's why I in part think that humility really is a strength. So a lot of people think of humility as a weakness, but I think that the people who are truly humble, that who can demonstrate that security,
我们在自己心中对自己的看法。我们是有缺陷的。我们是有限的。我们这些相互伤害、不如我们想象的那么高尚的有界生物。因此，谦逊的诚实既可怕又解放。这就是为什么我认为谦逊确实是一种力量。所以很多人认为谦逊是一种弱点，但我认为真正谦逊的人，能够表现出那种安全感的人，
they're demonstrating a strength to say, I have weaknesses, right? I'm not perfect. The way I see the world is not perfect. I'm not perfect in my relationships. And oftentimes, not always, but oftentimes when we show that kind of vulnerability, we are met with compassion or we are met with empathy, maybe even more than we might imagine, which is why we oftentimes try to keep that veneer up. We try to keep that facade and not allow people to see those more shameful parts of ourselves. You say that our culture pushes us in ways
他们表现出一种力量，说：我有弱点，对吧？我不完美。我看世界的方式并不完美。我在人际关系中并不完美。通常情况下，虽然不总是这样，但通常当我们表现出这种脆弱性时，我们会遇到同情或同理心，甚至可能比我们想象的还要多，这就是为什么我们经常试图保持这种外表。我们试图保持这种虚假的外表，不让人们看到我们身上那些更可耻的部分。你说我们的文化在推动我们
that make it hard to practice humility. You call this the culture's moving sidewalk. Do you have an example of this from your own life, Daryl? Yeah, so I mean, every day I wake up, I have to really commit to saying, okay, I'm going to try to be more humble today than it was the day before. Because I think it's very easy whether we get on social media, whether we're trying to promote ourselves professionally, whether we're comparing ourselves athletically or financially to other people,
这使得践行谦逊变得困难。你称之为文化的移动人行道。你自己的生活中有这方面的例子吗，达里尔？是的，我的意思是，每天我醒来，我都必须真正承诺说，好吧，我今天要努力比昨天更谦逊。因为我认为无论我们是上社交媒体，还是试图在职业上提升自己，还是在运动或经济上与他人进行比较，这都非常容易，
it's very easy to develop a sense of conditional self-worth. And so I think for a lot of people, that moving sidewalk is conditional self-worth. I'm only good enough if my bank account is this, or my achievements are this, or my travels are this. And what we do is we put our happiness, we put our value in the hands of other people to give us the validation that we so desperately need to say,
很容易产生有条件的自我价值感。所以我认为对很多人来说，这种移动的人行道就是有条件的自我价值。只有当我的银行存款达到这个水平，或者我的成就是这个水平，或者我的旅行是这个水平时，我才足够优秀。我们要做的就是把我们的快乐、我们的价值交到别人手里，让他们给我们极度需要的肯定，说：
yes, you are enough, you have traveled enough, you are successful enough in your career, you are cultured or interesting enough. And really, unless we're actively trying to work against that and free ourselves from that and cultivate an unconditional self-regard where we know that we're inherently worthy and loved and valued and enough in and of ourselves.
是的，你已经足够了，你已经旅行得够多了，你在事业上已经足够成功了，你的文化修养或兴趣已经足够了。真的，除非我们积极努力去对抗这一点，把它从我们身上解放出来，并培养一种无条件的自我尊重，即我们知道我们在本质上是有价值的、被爱的、被重视的，并且凭我们自己就已经足够了。
We're gonna fall prey to these narcissistic traps of our culture. And when we do, we stop living according to our values and we start chasing the approval of other people that's always going to be a moving target. You know, it's interesting, you told me at the start that you grew up in a very religious Christian household. I'm hearing echoes of, you know, may he who is without sin
我们将成为我们文化中自恋陷阱的牺牲品。当我们这样做时，我们就不再按照我们的价值观生活，而是开始追逐别人永远是一个不断移动的目标的认可。你知道，很有趣，你在开始时告诉我，你是在一个非常虔诚的基督教家庭中长大的。我听到了一些回声，你知道，愿那个没有罪的人
cast the first stone. When I hear a talk about, you know, let's be open about the things that are wrong with us. Yeah, that's right. Rushing to judging other people, you know, I was taught is just going to bring judgment on yourself, right? Pride comes before the fall, right? God loves the humble, but opposes the proud. So those types of things, and really just any of the world religions kind of highlighting features of the human condition where we are bounded, where we are a little bit more selfish, where we could do better to become nobler and more thoughtful of our fellow humans, really as a path toward virtuous flourishing
投下第一块石头。当我听到关于“让我们对我们身上不好的事情保持开放的态度”的言论时。是的，那是对的。我被教导说，急于评判他人只会给自己招致审判，对吧？骄傲在跌倒之前，对吧？上帝爱谦卑的人，却阻挡骄傲的人。所以诸如此类的事情，实际上只是任何世界宗教都突出了人类状况的特征，即我们是有界的，我们更自私一点，我们可以做得更好，以变得更高尚、对同胞更有深思熟虑，这确实是通往美德繁荣的道路
and enlightenment. Daryl says that one path to humility is to listen to feedback without becoming defensive. He struggles with this himself. When he was writing his book on humility, he asked his wife for feedback on one of his chapters. So when I asked her for feedback, she very kindly, thoughtfully sat down with me and said, you know, it's it's okay but you could do a lot better. And she really walked through and kind of highlighted the places in the chapter where I wasn't being honest, I wasn't being vulnerable. And in fact, I wasn't bringing my full self to the chapter. So at the end,
和启蒙。达里尔说，通往谦逊的一条途径是倾听反馈而不产生防御心理。他自己也很难做到这一点。当他在写关于谦逊的书时，他请妻子对其中的一章给出反馈。所以当我向她征求反馈时，她非常亲切、体贴地坐下来对我说，你知道，这还可以，但你可以做得更好。她真的通读了一遍，并指出了那一章中我不诚实、不脆弱的地方。事实上，我并没有把真实的自己带进这一章。所以最后，
she's like, you know, it's kind of a mediocre chapter and it's a rather important one. I immediately got defensive. I mean, if you're seeing a theme here, she gives me good feedback. I feel insecure. I respond defensively. And so here she is trying to help me improve the chapter. And I respond by not listening to her feedback and telling her, well, I can't do that. And I said it the best way I could. And I don't think you quite understand the research. I mean, the fact that she hung in there with me and still said, I think you can do better is really a testament to her patience and kindness. And truthfully, once I kind of set aside my ego and once I apologize for acting so terribly towards her and defensively, I was able to go back and revisit and she was able to talk through and I was able to hear when she was talking through that chapter. And I really reworked that chapter. And in fact, I spent so much more time on that chapter. And since then, I've gotten a number of
她说，你知道，这有点平庸，而且这一章相当重要。我立刻开启了防御模式。我的意思是，如果你在这里看到一个规律的话：她给我好的反馈，我感到不安全，我做出防御性的回应。所以她在这里试图帮我修改好这一章，而我的回应却是不听她的反馈，告诉她，嗯，我做不到。我已经尽我所能写出来了。而且我觉得你不太懂这项研究。我的意思是，她居然能忍受我，并且还说“我觉得你可以写得更好”，这真的是对她耐心和善良的证明。说实话，一旦我放下自我，一旦我为自己对她那种糟糕的防御性行为道歉，我就能够回去重新审视，她也能够和我一起讨论，当她讨论那一章时我能够听得进去了。我真的重新修改了那一章。事实上，我在那一章上花了更多的时间。从那以后，我有幸得到了很多
people who have commented that that chapter, and in particular, the sections that my wife offered improvements around, are their favorite parts of the book. And so, it's one of those, again, when I'm insecure, I stop listening and I get defensive. But when I'm open to that feedback, it just makes things better. But of course, the other theme that has come up repeatedly in this conversation is that defensiveness is driven by fear and insecurity. It's not just coming from a place of intellectual disagreement, it's coming from a place of emotional fear. That's exactly right. I was afraid, I was insecure, I was defensive about feeling ashamed and embarrassed.
人们评论说那一章，尤其是我的妻子提出改进意见的部分，是他们全书中最喜欢的部分。所以，这又是那种情况，当我缺乏安全感时，我就停止倾听并开始防备。但当我接受这种反馈时，事情就会变得更好。当然，在这次对话中反复出现的主题是，防御性是由恐惧和不安全感驱动的。它不仅来自智力上的分歧，还来自情感上的恐惧。完全正确。我很害怕，我很缺乏安全感，我为感到羞耻和尴尬而进行防御。
So you say that we can all look for humility role models, people who embody the virtues we'd like to develop in ourselves. In your book, you write about a businessman named Chuck Feeney. What was the story there? So Chuck Feeney grew up in a working class background, went to Cornell, and then helped found duty-free shoppers. So you've probably, if you've traveled internationally, you've seen these duty-free places where you can buy different merchandise and airports. Yeah. He amassed, I think it was $8 billion over his lifetime. But what was so impressive about Chuck Feeney was that he gave almost all of it away completely anonymously. And so,
所以你说我们可以寻找谦逊的榜样，那些体现了我们希望在自己身上发展的优秀品质的人。在你的书中，你写了一个名叫查克·费尼的商人。那里的故事是怎样的？查克·费尼在工人阶级背景中长大，去康奈尔大学上学，然后帮助创立了免税购物店。所以你可能，如果你在国际旅行过，你已经见过这些免税店，你可以在机场买到不同的商品。是的。我记得他一生中积累了 80 亿美元。但查克·费尼最令人印象深刻的是，他几乎把所有的钱都完全匿名捐出去了。所以，
some people like to give away money and are perfectly fine with their name attached to it, and some actually want their name attached to it. That's not at all what Chuck wanted. In fact, it was only because of a business deal that required that his identity being made public that anyone realized that he was this, you know, kind of James Bond of philanthropy, as someone once wrote about him, that he was secretly giving away all of his wealth
有些人喜欢捐钱，并且完全不介意把自己的名字附在上面，有些人甚至希望把自己的名字附在上面。查克根本不是这样。事实上，只是因为一笔商业交易要求公开他的身份，大家才意识到他是这个，你知道的，某种慈善界的詹姆斯·邦德，正如某人曾经写过关于他的那样，他秘密地捐出了他所有的财富，
and living this modest life where he flew coach, you know, ate hamburgers and lived in an apartment. So why was he doing it? What was his motivation? You know, my sense of his motivation is that he felt like he had enough and he felt empathically motivated to give towards others, that he had this spirit of generosity. But his spirit of generosity wasn't anchored in wanting to make sure that he got
过着坐经济舱、吃汉堡、住公寓的简朴生活。那他为什么要这么做？他的动机是什么？你知道，我对他的动机的理解是，他觉得自己已经够了，他有同理心地被激励去向他人捐赠，他有一种慷慨的精神。但他慷慨的精神并没有锚定在确保自己获得
credit for being generous, but it was in this true altruistic sense of, I have enough. I know what it's like not to have enough. I empathically can see that what I've earned can change radically the lives of other people and I want to invest in that, but I don't need the credit. I'm secure enough to know that what I'm doing is good in and of its own right. And so there's that theme again, which is that when we are secure and we feel confident, we don't need in some ways the world to stroke us as we might otherwise. That's absolutely right. So we talked earlier about the importance of
因慷慨而受到赞誉，而是出于这种真正利他主义的感觉：我足够了。我知道不够是什么滋味。我凭同理心可以看出，我所赚取的可以从根本上改变其他人的生活，我想为此投资，但我不需要赞誉。我有足够的安全感，知道我正在做的事情本身就是好的。所以这又是那个主题，那就是当我们有安全感并且感到自信时，我们在某种程度上并不需要世界像我们本可能那样去抚摸我们。完全正确。所以我们之前讨论了
humility in personal relationships, and you say this often involves giving up the desire to be right when we may be trampling on the feelings of other people. You had a fight with your wife in the first year of your marriage when you didn't follow this advice. Can you tell us what happened? Yeah, I think it was probably one of our first actual kind of significant disagreements that we got into. And as we're starting in this fight, my whole goal in this fight was just to win the fight. So I went from husband into lawyer mode, and I started asking her, well, what about this? And show me the evidence for that and interrogating her memory. And in the end, I quote unquote won the fight, but I did significant damage to the
个人关系中的谦逊，你说这通常涉及放弃想要正确的欲望，当我们在践踏别人的感情时。你在结婚第一年就和妻子吵过架，当时你没有听从这个建议。能告诉我们发生了什么吗？是的，我想这可能是我们发生的第一次实际意义上的重大分歧。当我们开始这场争吵时，我在这场争吵中的唯一目标就是赢得这场争吵。所以我从丈夫模式切换到了律师模式，我开始问她，嗯，那这个呢？并向我展示这方面的证据，并审问她的记忆。最后，我“赢得”了这场争吵，但我对
relationship. And the point, you know, throughout that argument, I was probably belittling and disrespectful and humiliating just to try to win the fight. And in the moment, I lost the entire perspective of the relationship. I lost the point that here's two people, we had just gotten married, we're trying our best to make it work, we're trying to create this new life together. If she's coming to me with a disagreement, the idea is that we can work collaboratively together to solve this problem. Do you remember what the fight was about? You see, that's the most ironic and terrible thing about it is I can't even remember what it was about.
关系。关键是，你知道，在那场争论中，我可能贬低、不尊重且羞辱了她，只是为了试图赢得这场争论。那一刻，我完全失去了对关系的整体视角。我忘记了，这里有两个人，我们刚结婚，我们正在尽最大努力让它成功，我们正试图一起创造这个新生活。如果她带着分歧来找我，这个想法是我们能够共同合作来解决这个问题。你还记得那场争吵是为了什么吗？你看，最讽刺、最糟糕的是我甚至记不清是为了什么了。
But at the moment, it felt so important to win the fight, even though now and probably in the moment, it was so inconsequential. Yeah. How are you connecting this with the idea of humility? Where does humility come in here, Daryl? Humility allows me to take that pause and for me to realize that first of all, I could be wrong. Don't go in assuming I'm right and trying to prove my case. Chances are I'm wrong, at least partially wrong. The second place where humility comes in is it allows me to reign in
但在那一刻，赢得争吵感觉太重要了，尽管现在和可能在当时，它是如此微不足道。是的。你是如何将这一点与谦逊联系起来的？达里尔，谦逊在哪里发挥作用？谦逊让我能够停下来，让我首先意识到我可能是错的。不要带着我是对的假设进去并试图证明我的观点。我有可能是错的，至少部分是错的。谦逊发挥作用的第二个地方是它允许我控制
those impulses and prioritize the well-being of other people. In this case, it would be my wife, or even more broadly, our relationship. So what we can do is we can actually think about our relationship as that third thing in the disagreement. So there's me, there's my wife, then there's our relationship. And what am I doing in our disagreement to make sure our relationship stays nourished? Am I staying on task? Am I not bringing up previous fights?
那些冲动，并把其他人的福祉放在首位。在这种情况下，会是我的妻子，或者更广泛地说，是我们的关系。所以我们可以做的是，我们实际上可以把我们的关系视为争论中的“第三者”。所以有我，有我的妻子，然后是我们的关系。在我们的争论中，我做了什么来确保我们的关系得到滋养？我专注于任务了吗？我没有提起以前的争吵吗？
Am I not bringing in extraneous people or disagreements with other family members? And then are we trying to just productively solve the problem at hand while respectfully and kindly listening to one another? So I'm wondering, Daryl, in the intervening years, have you tried to do things differently with your wife? What do you try and do when you have this urge to basically prove that you're right in an argument? So, I'm admittedly still not perfect.
我没有引入外人或其他家庭成员的分歧吗？然后我们是否只是试图富有成效地解决手头的问题，同时又尊重大方地互相倾听？所以我很好奇，达里尔，在随后的几年里，你有没有试着用不同的方式对待你的妻子？当你产生这种在争论中证明自己是对的的冲动时，你通常会怎么做？所以，我必须承认我仍然不完美。
I'm trying to get better. But some of the things that I do is I will try to pause and I ask myself, what am I feeling so insecure about? Why am I acting so reactively in this moment? Because sometimes my insecurity is not about what's going on in this moment. It's about what that moment represents or something else in my life that's made me feel insecure and it's coming out in this particular situation
我在努力变得更好。但我做的一些事情是，我会试着停下来，问自己：我到底在为什么感到缺乏安全感？为什么我在这一刻表现得如此具有反应性？因为有时我的不安全感与此时此刻发生的事情无关。而是关于那一刻所代表的东西，或者我生活中的其他事情让我感到缺乏安全感，而它在这个特定情况下表现出来了
or this particular argument. You know, even just last week, my wife and I were trying to pick out a few things for a home improvement project that we're doing and we were in the moment and, you know, we started getting into a, what seemed like an insignificant kind of disagreement about, you know, what size materials we needed for the project. And she said something and I completely disregarded her and she's like, Hey, I
或者这个特定的争论。你知道，就在上周，我和妻子正试图为我们正在进行的家居装修项目挑选一些东西，当时我们正处于那一刻，你知道，我们开始陷入一场看起来微不足道的争论，关于项目需要多大尺寸的材料。她说了些什么，而我完全无视了她，她说：“嘿，我
don't think you're listening to me. And I was about to respond saying, yes, I am. And I took a moment. I paused and I said, Hey, you know what? I'm really sorry. You're right, I didn't hear you. Can I hear that again? And she, and you know, we worked through it and then later she said, hey you know what, you're getting better at this. I appreciate you making an intentional effort to build in a little bit more space and hear me. I can see that you're working on that. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"]
觉得你没在听我说话。”我正要回答说：不，我有在听。然后我花了一点时间。我停顿了一下，说：“嘿，你知道吗？我真的很抱歉。你说的对，我没听。我能再听一遍吗？”然后她，你知道，我们解决了这个问题，后来她说：“嘿，你知道吗，你在这方面越来越好了。我很感激你有意腾出多一点空间来倾听我。我能看出你在为此努力。”
Some weeks ago, my daughter and I were out in nature. We were out on a beautiful lake, boating late at night with a group of friends. Our guide was telling us about the constellations in the night sky and how the light we were seeing was coming to us from the distant past because the stars were so far away. I remember thinking that the starlight I was seeing may have begun its journey to Earth long before humans first stepped foot on the planet. It made me reflect on how small we all were, how brief our time is on the planet.
几周前，我和女儿去大自然中。我们去了一个美丽的湖泊，深夜和一群朋友一起划船。我们的导游给我们讲述了夜空中的星座，以及我们看到的星光是如何从遥远的过去传过来的，因为星星离我们太远了。我记得当时我在想，我看到的星光可能在人类首次踏上地球之前很久就已经开始了通往地球的旅程。这让我反思我们是多么渺小，我们在地球上的时间是多么短暂。
In our companion story to this episode, we explore one final dimension to Daryl Van Tongren's research. We explore the psychology of existential humility and learn how it can help us transform our lives. That episode is available on our subscription feed, Hidden Brain Plus, and it's titled, Asking the Big Questions. If you're already a subscriber, you can listen to that episode right now. If you're not a subscriber, you can sign up by searching for HiddenBrain on Apple Podcasts or by going to apple.co. slash hidden brain. If you have an Android phone or are a member of Patreon, you can also access HiddenBrain Plus by going to our Patreon page at support.hiddenbrain.org. Daryl Van Tongren is a psychologist at Hope College and the author of Humble, Free Yourself
在本集的伴侣故事中，我们探讨了达里尔·范·唐格伦研究的最后一个维度。我们探讨存在主义谦逊的心理学，并了解它如何帮助我们改变生活。该集可在我们的订阅源 Hidden Brain Plus 上收看，标题为“提出重大问题”。如果您已经是订阅者，您现在就可以收听该集。如果您还不是订阅者，您可以通过在 Apple Podcasts 上搜索 HiddenBrain 或访问 apple.co. slash hidden brain 来注册。如果您拥有 Android 手机或 是 Patreon 会员，您还可以通过访问我们的 Patreon 页面 support.hiddenbrain.org 来访问 HiddenBrain Plus。达里尔·范·唐格伦 (Daryl Van Tongren) 是霍普学院的心理学家，也是《谦逊：让自己摆脱自恋世界的陷阱》(Humble, Free Yourself from the Traps of a Narcissistic World) 一书的作者。达里尔，非常感谢你今天来到 Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
from the Traps of a Narcissistic World. Daryl, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
我是 Hidden Brain 的执行主编。如果您认识可能会喜欢今天这一集的人，请与他们分享。您的口碑推荐对于帮助我们为 Hidden Brain 探讨的想法联系新听众至关重要。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you know someone who might enjoy today's episode, please share it with them. Your word of mouth recommendations are vital to helping us connect new listeners with the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。如果你认识可能会喜欢今天节目的朋友，请分享给他们。你的口碑推荐对于帮助我们让新听众了解我们在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨的理念至关重要。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。